passeur sur public sénat
bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant l'audition de didier
migaud devant la commission des finances
du sénat
le premier président de la cour des
comptes est ici en sa qualité de
président du haut conseil des finances
publiques
il présente devant la commission des
finances du sénat les conclusions de
l'avis relatif au projet de loi de
finances 2014
bercy a basé son projet sur des
prévisions de croissance que le haut
conseil juge plausible même si didier
migaud va évoquer quelques éléments de
fragilité
voilà tout de suite direction la salle
clemenceau monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur général
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie d'avoir bien voulu
m'inviter devant votre commission en
tant que président du haut conseil des
finances publiques pour vous présenter
les principales conclusions de l'avis
relatif au projet de loi de finances et
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014
je suis accompagné du nouveau rapporteur
général du haut conseil des finances
publiques françois meunier qui a pris
ses fonctions le 1er octobre en
remplacement de jean philippe cotis ce
qui est parti pour d'autres fonctions
dans une banque
francois monier magistrat honoraire à la
cour des comptes que la commission
d'ailleurs des affaires sociales de
votre assemblée a pu auditionner à
plusieurs reprises dans ses fonctions de
secrétaire général de la commission des
comptes de la sécurité sociale et il a
pu participer aux travaux de préparation
de notre avis ma compagne également
philippe
ravalée annabelle murugan et nathalie
georges ainsi qu'il tienne sa nicolau
qui est à la manoeuvre avec l'ordinateur
qui est stagiaire
voilà vous avez avec ces personnes là la
petite équipe du haut conseil avec boris
muppets qui aujourd'hui est en
déplacement
alors si vous me le permettez je
présente très brièvement dans un premier
temps les principales conclusions de
l'avis adopté par le haut conseil
je suis bien sûr ensuite à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
alors comme vous le savez la france
s'est engagée vis-à-vis de ses
partenaires européens à atteindre en
l' équilibre structurel des comptes
publics
cet engagement a été traduit dans la loi
du 31 décembre 2012 de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2012
à 2017
ici les ministres des finances de
l'union européenne se sont accordés en
juin pour desserrer le calendrier en
matière de déficit nominal de déficit
effectif
ils ont maintenu l'échéance de 2016 pour
le retour à l'équilibré structurel des
comptes publics
alors il revient au conseil d'émettre un
avis en toute indépendance sur les
projets de loi de finances et de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
notre mission en réalité est double
premièrement le haut conseil doit se
prononcer sur les prévisions macro
économiques associés au projet de loi de
finances et de financement de la
sécurité sociale
le haut conseil ne produit pas ses
propres prévisions
mais il s'appuie sur les statistiques
disponibles ainsi que sur les prévisions
et les analyses d'un ensemble
d'organismes tels que l'insee la banque
de france la banque centrale européenne
le fmi et le cd nous le faisons en toute
transparence ainsi que l'a souhaité
d'ailleurs votre assemblée en
mentionnant les prévisions et analyses
que nous utilisons pour la vie que nous
exprimons deuxièmement le haut conseil
doit examiner la cohérence de l'article
leamy
r du projet de loi de finances de
l'année au regard des orientations
pluriannuelles de solde structurel
défini dans la loi de programmation et
pour la première fois en effet le projet
de loi de finances contient un article
liminaire qui présente les prévisions de
soldes effectifs et de solde structurel
des administrations publiques pour
l'année en cours 2013
et bien sûr pour l'année à venir 2014
alors à ce stade permettez moi
d'apporter trois précisions sur cette
notion de cohérence s'agit d'abord d'une
notion difficile à appréhender
si nous prenons le dictionnaire des 1000
litres et et cohérent ce qui tient
réciproquement ensemble la mission du
haut conseil ne peut se limiter à une
simple vérification de la concordance
des chiffres entre le tableau présenté à
l'article liminaires et celui arrêté
dans la loi de programmation si c'était
cela vous n'auriez pas besoin au conseil
de finances publiques il ne peut s'agir
non plus d'un examen ligne à ligne en
recettes et en dépenses du projet de loi
de finances et du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
le haut conseil droite analysé les
prévisions de sol des administrations
publiques
au vu des prévisions macroéconomiques du
gouvernement et des éléments qui lui ont
été communiquées sur les principales
dispositions des plf et plfss et les
comparer aux objectifs fixés dans la loi
de programmation
or au delà du respect formel de la
trajectoire il revient dos au conseil
d'apprécier le degré de robustesse et
les éventuels éléments de fragilité du
scénario de finances publiques et en
particulier de la trajectoire du solde
structurel
compte tenu des informations dont il
dispose ensuite la trajectoire de
référence utilisé pour examiner la
cohérence de l'article liminaire doit
être mise en perspective les
dispositions de la loi organique nous
invite à identifier les écarts avec les
orientations pluriannuelles de solde
structurel arrêté dans la dernière loi
de programmation promu lier le 31
décembre 2012
depuis l'adoption de cette dernière le
contexte a pu toutefois évolué et nous
devons en tenir compte et donc ne pas
nous livrer une analyse statique des
données fournies
enfin cette analyse de cohérence
nécessite des informations nombreuses et
donc des délais d'examen raisonnable je
souhaite saluer la qualité des
informations qui ont été communiquées au
conseil dès le mois de juillet par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
sur le scénario macro économique et de
finances publiques des réponses
détaillées ont ensuite été adressées aux
demandes des membres cela a permis
d'avoir deux premiers échanges fructueux
entre le haut conseil et les
administrations compétentes et constitue
un progrès notable par rapport aux deux
précédents exercices auxquels s'étaient
livrés le haut conseil nous avions pu
déplorer un certain retard dans les
informations qui nous étaient
communiqués
or ces efforts doivent être poursuivis
afin d'améliorer le cadre des échanges
qui se poursuivent au mois de septembre
en particulier la saisine du premier
ministre intervenu le 13 septembre ne
contenait pas formellement tous les
éléments permettant au conseil d'
apprécier la cohérence de l'arctique
liminaire avec les orientations
pluriannuelles des éléments concernant
notamment les finances publiques étaient
peu développées
ils ont dû être précisé par la suite
laissant peu de temps vous conseille
pour les analyser et je veux rappeler
qu'il est indispensable que le haut
conseil dispose d'un délai d'au moins
une semaine pour examiner de façon
satisfaisante le contenu du projet de
loi de finances et du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
il serait donc souhaitable qu'à l'avenir
la saisine du premier ministre
contiennent tous les éléments
nécessaires à la préparation de la vie
en supposant bien sûr que tous les
arbitrages soient rendus à cette date ce
qui n'était pas tout à fait le cas
semble-t-il
j'en viens à présent trois principales
conclusions de cet avis alors s'agissant
des prévisions macroéconomiques tout
d'abord le haut conseil considère que
les prévisions de croissance sont
plausibles
le scénario du gouvernement qui repose
sur une reprise modérée de l'activité
avec une croissance de 0,1 pour cent en
2013 et de 0,9 en 2014 semble
raisonnable pour 2013 la prévision est
conforté par l'amélioration cours de
l'été des perspectives économiques à
court terme et pour 2014
la prévision de croissance se situent
dans le consensus des économistes dont
la moyenne s'établit à 0,8 pour cent
le haut conseil a toutefois identifié
des éléments de fragilité
ainsi que des aléas globalement orientés
à la baisse pour 2014 entourant le
scénario macroéconomique du gouvernement
parmi les éléments de fragilité de ce
scénario le haut conseil juge les
prévisions d'emploi optimiste je
souhaiterais à cet égard attiré
l'attention de votre commission sur
l'importance des prévisions d'emploi au
même titre que celle de croissance qui
focalise le débat public comme vous le
savez l'évolution de l'emploi exercent
des effets importants à la fois sur le
dynamisme de l'activité économique et
l'équilibré des comptes publics des
hypothèses trop favorables peuvent
conduire d'une part à une surestimation
de la masse salariale et partant des
recettes de cotisations sociales et de
csg et d'autre part à une
sous-estimation des dépenses d'assurance
chômage
or le gouvernement anticipe selon nous
des créations d'emploi particulièrement
vigoureuse dans les secteurs marchands
et non marchands
ce scénario de forte reprise de l'emploi
suscite trois interrogations
s'agissant du secteur non marchand la
forte croissance de l'emploi en moyenne
annuelle repose sur une hypothèse
volontariste de montée en charge du
dispositif d'emplois aidés sont les
contrats d'avenir essentiellement à la
fin de 2013 et tout au long de 2014
s'agissant du secteur marchand le
contenu de la croissance en emplois par
est élevé même avant la prise en compte
des effets du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
le haut conseil considère en effet que
compte tenu du faible niveau de
productivité consécutif à la crise
majeure que nous venons de koné
entre la reprise de la croissance
pourrait se traduire dans l'immédiat
davantage par un rattrapage de
productivité que par une augmentation
des embauches
en outre les effets attendus par le
gouvernement du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi semblent surestimer
le haut conseil considère d'une part que
le cic ne peut pas comme le gouvernement
le fait purement assimilé au plan
économique à une baisse de charges sur
les salaires
d'autre part dans le contexte de faible
niveau de marge que connaissent les
entreprises une baisse des charges
d'exploitation risque d'avoir à court
terme moins d'impact sur l'emploi que ne
laisse contre le gouvernement le haut
conseil également identifié un certain
nombre d'aléas qui entoure la prévision
de croissance du gouvernement
il porte essentiellement sur
l'environnement extérieur de la france
et sont globalement orientés à la baisse
en particulier un environnement
international moins porteur ou
l'assainissement différé du secteur
bancaire européen pourrait peser sur les
perspectives de croissance pour 2014
al'inverse des avancées plus rapide
qu'attendu en matière de gouvernance
économique et financière européenne
pourrait conduire à un rebond plus franc
de l'activité en 2014
en définitive le haut conseil estime que
la prévision de croissance qui vous est
présenté est plausible mais que le
scénario macroéconomique présente des
éléments de fragilité notamment sur les
prévisions d'emploi
permettez moi maintenant de présenter
les conclusions de l'avis sur la
cohérence de l'arctique liminaire avec
les orientations pluriannuelles de solde
structurel
un premier constat s'impose le déficit
structurel prévu tant pour 2013 que pour
2014 est significativement supérieur à
celui de la loi de programmation
selon l'article liminaire présenté par
le gouvernement le solde structurel
s'établirait à -2 6% du pib en 2013 et
-1 7% en 2014 contre respectivement -1
26% pour 2013 et moins 1,1
pour 2014 dans la loi de programmation
les écarts s'élèverait donc à un point
en 2013 est encore à 0,6 point en 2014
or s'agissant de 2013 il convient de
distinguer nous avions d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion d'un premier échange à ce
sujet ce qui est héritée du passé et ce
qui résulte d'un ajustement structurel
c'est à dire une amélioration du solde
structurel inférieur à ce qui était
initialement prévu une partie de l'écart
0,3 point et hérité de celui constaté en
2012 par le haut conseil dans son avis
du 23 mai 2013 et que j'avais l'occasion
déjà de vous présenter une large part de
cet écart était imputable à des
révisions des comptes nationaux de 2011
par l'insee sur le p-dg comme sur le
déficit public le reste de lait car un
petit 0,7 point est imputable à un
ajustement structurel moins rapide que
prévu en raison d'une surestimation dans
le projet de loi de finances pour 2013
et dans la loi de programmation pour
l'année concernée du dynamisme des
recettes par rapport à la croissance du
pib' l'élasticité global des recettes
seraient en effet de 0,5 contre 1
initialement prévue
et cette différence d'élasticité se
traduit par un moindre ajustement
structurel de 0,4 point de pim sur
l'écart totale de 0,7 point propre à
2013 pour le solde cela résulte d'un
rendement moindre que prévu de certaines
mesures nouvelles votées en loi de
finances pour 2013 de l'ordre de 0,1
point et d'une évolution plus rapide des
dépenses en volume de l'ordre de 0,1
point en raison de la révision de la
prévision d'inflation d'une dynamique un
peu plus forte de la dépense locale
ainsi que d'un versement supplémentaire
de 1 milliard 800 millions au budget de
l'ue
on européenne or s'agissant de 2014
l'effort supplémentaire prévue par le
gouvernement
0,4 point ne permettrait de rattraper
une partie du retard accumulé en 2013 un
point conduisant ainsi à l'écart prévues
dont je parlais tout à l'heure de 0,6
point 2 surprend le haut conseil estime
que cette prévision de déficit
structurel pour 2014 est optimiste alors
pourquoi il a notamment identifié sans
les chiffrer
quatre facteurs qui conduisent à penser
que ce déficit structurel pourrait être
sous-estimée s'agissant des recettes
tout d'abord les hypothèses d'élasticité
du gouvernement votre puce qui mesurent
la réactivité des recettes fiscales et
sociales à la croissance du pi
paraissent optimistes
le gouvernement anticipe une
augmentation à législation constante
proche de celle du pib' il ya une
élasticité qui comprise entre 0,9 et 1
le haut conseil estime de ce côté que
les rentrées fiscales de 2014 pourrait
encore subir les effets négatifs de la
mauvaise conjoncture de 2013 notamment
en raison du décalage temporel entre le
calcul de l'assiette et la perception de
certains impôts le rendement aussi des
mesures nouvelles annoncées par le
gouvernement à hauteur de 9 milliards et
demi n'a pu être expertisés par le haut
conseil
cela concerne en particulier la
cotisation sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation de milliards et demi mais
je comprends que le gouvernement il ya
renoncé au profit d'une majoration du
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés
en outre le haut conseil n'a pas été
destinataire du détail des mesures
nouvelles concernant la fiscalité
écologique
ces 400 millions d'euros et la sécurité
sociale c'est 600 millions d'euros
enfin le rendement attendu d'un
renforcement de la lutte contre la
fraude et l'optimisation fiscale 1
milliard 800 millions est incertain une
partie pourrait ne pas être pérenne
s'agissant possiblement d'une mesure
ponctuelle et temporaire au sens des
textes européens
en ce qui concerne des dépenses
les dépenses des facteurs d'incertitude
ont été identifiés sur le champ de
l'état et des collectivités
territoriales
l'effort sur les dépenses de l'état est
conditionnée à une stricte maîtrise de
la masse salariale et au ralentissement
effective des dépenses d'intervention la
réduction des concours de l'état à
hauteur de 1 milliard 500 millions
d'euros collectivités territoriales ne
se traduira pas nécessairement par une
économie à due concurrence de la dépense
locale
par ailleurs je rappelle que les
prévisions de solde structurel repose
sur les hypothèses de croissance
potentielle retenue dans la loi de
programmation corps vous le savez le
haut conseil n'a pas été amené à se
prononcer sur ces hypothèses dans la
mesure où sa création est postérieur à
l'adoption de la dernière loi de
programmation
nous nous interrogeons néanmoins sur
l'ampleur de l'écart de production
estimée à trois points et demi en 2014
en effet dans le contexte de crise
financière majeure que nous venons de
connaître la persistance d'un déficit
d'activité devrait s'accompagner de
pertes définitives de capacités
productives pesant in fine et sur la
croissance potentielle
or un écart sur évalué entre le pub
effectifs et le pic potentiel conduit à
surestimer la composante conjoncturelle
et par votre conséquence à sous-estimer
le déficit structurel qui est la
référence principale retenu pour le
pilotage de nos finances publiques dans
le cadre européen
et si cette hypothèse se vérifiait les
efforts d'ajustement budgétaires
nécessaires pour atteindre l'équilibré
structurel s'entrouvre est accrue
le haut conseil ne pourra se prononcer
bien évidemment sur cette question qu'à
l'occasion du prochain projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
lui sera à présenter mais il lui a
semblé utile de relever ce point qui
participe d'une appréhension d'ensemble
de la situation de nos finances
publiques
après un premier écart de 0,3 point 2012
constaté par le haut conseil le solde
structurel s'écarterait dès 2013
significativement de la trajectoire
programme et nécessitant
vraisemblablement le déclenchement du
mécanisme de correction mois de mai 2014
aux termes de l'article 23 de la loi
organique le mécanisme de correction est
déclenchée si le haut-conseil identifié
un écart important entre les résultats
de l'année écoulée et les orientations
pluriannuelles de solde structurel
défini par la loi de programmation
alors deux critères alternatifs
permettent de déterminer si un écart est
important ou non s'il représente au
moins 0,5 point de pipe sur une année
donnée ou au moins 0,25 point de pub en
moyenne sur deux années consécutives
dans son avis du 23 mai 2013 le haut
conseil avait déjà constaté un écart de
0 3 point en 2012
devant cette même commission j'avais
souligné que cet écart présentait un
risque s'agissant du respect futur de la
trajectoire ce risque se confirme avec
le projet de loi de finances qui vous
est prévu une présenter si les
prévisions du gouvernement se réalise
le mécanisme de correction sera
déclenché en mai 2014 sauf à modifier la
loi de programmation et le calendrier de
redressement des finances publiques
s'agissant de sa composante structurelle
la capacité de la france à atteindre
l'équilibré structurel des finances
publiques en 2016 objectif sur lequel
elle s'est engagée dépend ainsi d'une
part de l'atteinte de l'objectif de
solde structurel fixé en 2014 ce qui
n'est pas évident à ce stade compte tenu
des hypothèses optimistes qui ont été
retenus et d'autre part et quand bien
même cet objectif serait respectée de la
mise en oeuvre en 2015 et 2016 d'efforts
plus importants que ceux prévus par la
loi de programmation
en effet cette dernière prévoyait un
ajustement de 1,1 point du pipe sur les
deux années
c'est désormais un ajustement de 1,7
point soit si on raisonne de façon égale
sur chacune des années 0,85 point par an
qui serait nécessaire pour atteindre l'
équilibre structurel si on veut vraiment
atteindre les héros là aussi sauf bien
évidemment à modifier la loi de
programmation et le calendrier de retour
à l'équilibré structurel
dans le rapport économique social et
financier rendu public le 1er octobre et
communiqué à la commission européenne le
gouvernement a annoncé un ajustement de
1,5 point en 2015 et 2016 soit non pas
les 0 85 que nous pointions mais 0.75
par an en moyenne
intégralement porter en dépenses et dans
ces conditions le solde structurel
s'établirait fin 2016 à moins 0,2 point
de pipe que la commission juge comme
étant l' équilibre structurel puisque il
doit y avoir ni qui dit structurel donc
1 0 mais avec un quart de point comme
souplesse et donc le haut conseil sera
amené à se prononcer sur ces hypothèses
dans ses prochains avis puisque le
rapport économique social et financier a
été rendu public après que nous ayons
exprimer notre avis dans son rapport
relatif au projet de loi organique
relatif à la programmation à la
gouvernance des finances publiques votre
rapporteur général monsieur marc formé
le voeu que le haut conseil des finances
publiques deviennent l'organisme de
référence dont la crédibilité des avis
améliorerait la gouvernance des finances
publiques
six mois après son installation je crois
que le haut conseil répond s'efforce de
répondre à vos attentes il a développé
une expertise indépendante sur les
textes financiers préalablement à leur
présentation au parlement il a ainsi
pour mission d'éclairer vos débats sur
les moyens mis en oeuvre pour la france
pour respecter ses engagements en
matière de finances publiques étant
entendu que c'est vous qui fixez les
objectifs et bien évidemment les moyens
pour y parvenir et j'espère que le
présent avis contribuera à éclairer
effectivement vos débats je vous
remercie de votre attention et nous
sommes à votre disposition pour répondre
à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
alors monsieur le rapporteur général
votre voeu at il été exaucé
c'est le président on l'a appelée eau
des voeux c'est dans quelques semaines
l'essence de temps s'écoule et ça va
être un temps très riche pour notre
commission ce que nous allons débattre
dans le détail des considérations
budgétaires et mais je peux dire
effectivement que à travers la vie écrit
qui nous a été communiquée et la
présentation que vient de faire un
instant le président didier migaud
nous avons bien le sentiment qu'il y
avait un maillon qui manquait dans la
chaîne de l'évaluation et de la
prévision économique pour rendre plus
crédible et plus clair les perspectives
dans lesquels on s'engage donc je viens
remercier didier migaud de la
présentation qui nous fait la rigueur
d'analysé qui est la sienne et également
de l'efficacité avec laquelle toute
l'équipe du haut conseil a préparé cet
avis que nous avons examinés avec soin
et que le gouvernement a bien sûr
veiller à prendre en considération
alors bien entendu ayant cdh rigueur d'
analyse le haut conseil peut aussi se
prêter parfois des commentaires à des
propos qui peuvent paraître un peu
prudent cet égard j'ai noté que dans
chacun de ces avis le haut conseil
insiste particulièrement sur les aléas
négatif qui a fait que les prévisions
macroéconomiques du gouvernement
donc ne pourrait-on pas considérer qu'il
s'agit d'un billet qui découlent
nécessairement des finalités du haut
conseil
monsieur le président ce qui
impliquerait de relativiser les
commentaires portant sur de tels aléas
d'autres termes est-ce que le haut
conseil n'aura pas tendance à voir la
bouteille plutôt à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein et dès lors
s'exprimer avec une prudence naturelle
mais qui peut parfois conduire les
décideurs politiques à vouloir à être un
peu plus ambitieux ou en tout cas plus
optimiste pour l'avenir mais c'est une
question qui peut être sort un peu du
champ de l'analyse rationnelle et qui
touche un petit peu au champ politique
deuxième question une question qui porte
sur les prévisions économiques le haut
conseil vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président a considéré que ses prévisions
économiques étaient plausibles ne
pourrai pont ne pourrait-on pas dire
même qu'elles étaient prudentes pas
prudent à l'excès mais parti gorran
prudente et pour dire cela je prend
appui sur les analyses qui sont faites
et qui ont été communiquées ces derniers
jours
je prends en considération par exemple
les informations qui me viennent du du
fmi en date du 8 octobre et qui
considère que pour la france on sera pas
à 0 1 mais plutôt à 0,2 pour l'année et
l'année prochaine plutôt à quoi 09
bon si on prend en considération de
telles prévisions du fmi on est tenté de
dire que finalement gouvernement est
prudent le gouvernant et prudent je ne
dit pas autre chose
donc est-ce que plausible n'est pas
finalement à une expression qui
temps à exprimer en sous-entendus
quelques réticences ou quelques
inquiétudes concernant la démarche qui
est suivie en tout cas si je prends
l'investissement des entreprises à titre
d'exemple l'évolution qui est prévu +1
5% et très modéré parce qu'on sait très
bien que quand il y a des périodes de
reprise généralement la progression de
l'investissement est plus importante que
star dont moi j'ai tendance à considérer
que les choses sont eux vu sous un angle
relativement prudent le haut niveau du
gouvernement
troisième question elle porte sur les
questions de l'emploi est sans doute à
juste raison sur le président vous avez
souligné qu'il y avait des fragilités
vous considérez en particulier le
rattrapage à la productivité et la
reconstitution des marges des
entreprises devrait sans doute ralentir
les créations d'emplois mais cette
analyse au fond ne sous-estime t'elle
pas les effets des politiques de
l'emploi menée par le gouvernement
notamment la mise en place des contrats
d'avenir des contrats de génération est
ce qu'il ya de ce point de vue une prise
en compte insuffisante de l'impact sur
l'emploi de ces dispositifs
une autre question concerne
les le solde structurel le conseil a
rappelé qu'il était en attente
je cite d'une définition explicite par
le gouvernement des mesures ponctuelles
et temporaires susceptibles d'être
exclues du solde structurel
fin de citation donc la question se pose
pour nous de savoir de quelle façon
était jusqu'à présent déterminer les
mesures considérées comme ponctuelles et
temporaires
selon vous quelle devrait être la
définition de ces mesures justement
puisque vous appeler le gouvernement à
préciser les choses quel est votre
sentiment sur la définition de ces
mesures
c'est important parce qu'on joue
vraiment sur des la des pourcentages de
croissance relativement faible mais 01
02 03 points c'est quelque chose
d'important dans le regard très précis
que vous souhaitez porter sur la
trajectoire de la france en la matière
alors s'agissant des aléas significatif
associé à l'environnement extérieur de
la france
je voulais vous interrogez suite à ce
que vous nous avez dit sur l'analyse que
vous faites de la situation américaine
en ce moment en particulier estimez vous
que la politique monétaire menée jusqu'à
présent par la banque centrale
américaine
puis c'est ta à l'origine d'une sorte de
reprise biaisée de l'économie comme cela
a pu être le cas par le passé et nous
avons cru comprendre depuis hier qu'il y
avait une nouvelle
présidente de la banque centrale
américaine qui allait être désigné avec
un certain nombre de deux points de vue
déjà connu quand la facilitation
monétaire pour aider la croissance à se
dynamiser ce qu'a d'ailleurs provoqué
quelques réjouissances au niveau de la
sphère financière des marchés boursiers
qui escompte dès lors que au fond il y
aura à nouveau un peu de facilitation et
j'utilise pas le mot de laxisme quant à
la gestion de la masse monétaire
mais toutes choses qui peuvent
effectivement conduire à une impression
de reprise artificielle puisque fondée
sur une augmentation de la masse
monétaire sur les bases un peu
artificielle enfin dernière question sur
les hypothèses de croissance de dépenses
publiques sur le président dans le cadre
de vos hypothèses de travail puisque
vous sembliez dire que celles qui
étaient retenus par le gouvernement ces
hypothèses de croissance de dépenses
publiques paraissait quelque peu
inapproprié ou en tout cas quelque peu
biaisée quels sont vos propres analyses
en la matière et d'autre part pourriez
vous nous dire comment
l'élasticité des recettes publiques
devrait-elle évolué en 2014 puisque vous
nous indiquer tout à l'heure que si le
solde structurel ne s'est pas autant
améliorer qu'on le souhaitait c'est
parce qu'il ya eu un défaut dans
l'élasticité des recettes publiques de 0
4 point
vous l'avez démontré dans votre
transparent sûr le pays et la croissance
du pib
donc qu'est-ce comptez-vous s'agissant
de cette élasticité en 2014 dans un
contexte où apparemment il semble que y
ait une reprise qui s'affirme et dès
lors peut-on dire que le coefficient
d'élasticité va évoluer
quels sont vos analyses sur ce point là
monsieur le président quelques points
d'interrogation qui souhaitait soumettre
au président
mais merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur général président didier
migaud va répondre à vos différentes
préoccupations en ce qui me concerne
j'aurais souhaité ajouter une question
qui m'est venu à l'esprit en écoutant le
ministre délégué bernard cazeneuve il y
a quelques jours lors de cette audition
monsieur le président ce ministre par
ailleurs très habile et a déclaré et
j'ouvre les guillemets le haut conseil
apprécie le décalage entre la loi de
finances et la loi de programmation
pluriannuelle des finances publiques
toutefois depuis une négociation a été
conduite avec l'union européenne et le
calendrier de nos engagements a été
redéfini ce qui nous a donné davantage
de temps pour atteindre nos objectifs
nous avons transmis ces éléments au haut
conseil qui se prononcera de nouveau en
mai nous aurons dans le courant de
l'année 2014 à regarder la manière dont
en liaison avec le haut conseil des
finances publiques
et là c'est moi qui souligne nous
mettons où nous mettrons en adéquation
la trajectoire avec notre budget alors
monsieur président meego j'aurais
souhaité savoir ce qu il convient selon
vous de penser de cette déclaration vous
demander si et vous pensez que cette
déclaration est est en ligne avec le
principe selon lequel la trajectoire des
finances publiques s'impose aux lois
financières
au lieu que ce soit la trajectoire qui
doivent être ajusté aux variations des
lois financières mais peut-être n'ai-je
pas compris ces sujets étant extrêmement
complexe il serait utile en tout cas que
notre commission puisse être aider à
interpréter les déclarations communes
budget a bien voulu faire de vente elle
merci je vais réserver ma réponse à
votre question monsieur le président
après avoir répondu aux questions posées
par le rapporteur général alors prudents
plausible aléas baissiers à les associer
ou tout au moins bon c'est dans chacun
de nos avis d'ailleurs nous parlons et
des aléas à la hausse et des aléas
possibles à la baisse bon ce que nous
avons dit s'agissant de 2014 c'est qu'il
nous apparaissait que les aléas à la
baisse était supérieure aux aléas
possibles à la hausse sans une fois de
plus les exclus on a dit qu' il n'était
pas exclue du tout qu'une que la
croissance soit supérieur au 09 proposé
par le
gouvernement donc c'est pour cela que
nous avons retenu le terme plausible si
nous avions distinguer entre 2013 et
je crois qu'on peut dire que sur 2013
c'est prudent sur 2014 c'est
effectivement plausible plausible ça
veut dire réaliste crédible
bon alors pourquoi nous avons insisté
sur un certain nombre de risques et
d'aléas
c'est ce que dit il il faut conserver
quand même à l'esprit que la crise que
nous venons de connaître et que nous
connaissons encore est tout à fait
exceptionnel
bon et que nous ne sommes pas totalement
dans une phase de reprise classique et
que des risques importants continuent de
peser sur la croissance mondiale et nous
les évoquons dans notre avis et non
seulement sur la croissance mondiale
mais également sur la croissance
européenne et je reviendrai sur sûr
c'est sur ces aléas qui pèsent sur
l'environnement international
bon il ya aussi des freins à la
croissance qui subsistent sur le plan
intérieur
bon j'aurais peut-être l'occasion d'y
revenir tout à l'heure mais nous avons
au niveau des entreprises des résultats
qui sont plutôt dégradée un taux
d'utilisation des capacités très bas qui
est bien évidemment tout cela pèse sur
l'investissement une progression du
pouvoir d'achat qui restent qui reste
modeste et un effort structurel de
réduction de déficit public moindre
qu'en 2013 mais encore substantielles
donc tout cela peut peser
donc voilà c'est ce qui nous nous a
permis de dire que
bon il y avait un certain nombre d'aléas
baissier de la même façon nous avons
exprimé quelques interrogations sur le
le scénario macroéconomique
disons que les hypothèses nous
apparaissent plausible mais au niveau du
scénario macroéconomique
bon il y avait un certain nombre
d'interrogations
ne serait ce que parce que le cil
l'hypothèse de croissance peut tout à
fait être atteinte
son contenu en emplois peut-être plus
décevant que nous le pensons que le
gouvernement pour un certain nombre de
raisons sur lesquelles je suis revenu
dans mon propos introductif sur lesquels
que vous avez vous même évoqué c'est à
dire que nous avons un retard en
productivité
et puis nous avons des marges des
entreprises qui sont qui sont faibles
bon donc du coup on peut penser que que
la reprise se fera se traduira d'abord
par un rattrapage de la productivité et
également par une reconstitution des
marges par les entreprises elles mêmes
avant même qu'elle ne ré embauche bon
c'est pour cela que nous avons souhaité
bien évidemment identifier cela
d'ailleurs dans les dents les dernières
prévisions de l'unedic
on retrouve je dirais le raisonnement
qu'a pu tenir le haut conseil
or sur l'emploi non marchand pour l'âge
insiste pas là dessus ça dépend bien
évidemment la 2de je dirais du programme
volontariste qui est mise en place par
le gouvernement c'est un programme qui
est ambitieux pour tout dépend des
moyens qui bien sûr sont consacrés pour
atteindre ses objectifs mais il n'ya pas
que l'emploi non marchand il ya aussi
l'emploi marchand qui peut être tout à
fait déterminant voilà c'est pour cela
que nous avons
insister là dessus et que nous avons
formulé un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur le scénario
macroéconomique est identifié un certain
nombre d'aléas négatifs notamment compte
tenu d'une d'un contexte international
particulier qui n'est pas complètement
sorti de la crise dans dans laquelle ce
monde ce monde était alors sur votre
question relative aux mesures
ponctuelles et temporaires
bon nous nous nous avons estimé
effectivement nécessaire que le
périmètre de ces mesures ponctuelles et
temporaires soit établie de façon claire
et précise et et nous avions notamment
dans notre avis publié en mai dernier
considéré que que la vente des licences
de fréquences hertziennes dont le
produit s'était élevé d'ailleurs 1,2
milliard 600 millions c'est-à-dire une
somme qui n'est pas négligeable aurait
dû être traité comme une mesure
ponctuelle et temporaires à l'instar par
exemple de ce qui a été fait en dépenses
pour la recapitalisation de dexia alors
que le gouvernement lui a donné un
statut différent et cela peut avoir bien
évidemment des conséquences ensuite dans
l'appréciation du solde structurel
alors nous avons saisi la direction
générale du trésor ainsi que la
direction du budget pour pour le moment
personne n'a vraiment eu le temps
semble-t-il de travailler sur ce sujet
la préparation 2 du plf peut expliquer
cela c'est un chantier que nous devons
reprendre avec le gouvernement en
liaison aussi avec la commission pour
que nous ayons la même définition et que
ça puisse être accepté et par la
commission et par le gouvernement nous
avons redit notre disponibilité pour y
travailler
de notre côté manifestement on voit bien
que des voies d'amélioration sont son
possible pour dégager une doctrine sur
ce sujet là et la france pourrait se
doter d'un corpus de règles en la
matière des voies d'amélioration sont
possibles aussi pour justifier
précisément le caractère ponctuel et
temporaire des mesures déduite du solde
structurel et puis je pense que ce
serait aussi utile que nous puissions
harmoniser le vocabulaire utilisé au
niveau européen les textes financiers
français font régulièrement mention de
mesures exceptionnelles et temporaires
bon c'est pas tout à fait de même
vocabulaire que celui utilisé par la
commission
bon donc ce serait bien d'avoir une
certaine cohérence en la matière vous
m'avez également interrogé sur la
situation de l'économie américaine
je veux rappeler tout d'abord que le
mandat du haut conseil
de donner un avis sur les prévisions
macroéconomiques de la france mais c'est
bien évidemment dans cette perspective
que nous suivons la conjoncture aux
états unis et le fait d'ailleurs que
nous identifions un certain nombre
d'aléas à la baisse compte tenu d'un
contexte international montre qu'il faut
que nous suivions aussi bien évidemment
des analyses qui peuvent exister sur la
situation d'un certain nombre de pays
alors on peut constater que l'activité a
accéléré aux états unis au second
semestre 2013 qu'elle devrait rebondir
en 2014
après le ralentissement de 2013 qui a
été induit par un effort budgétaire
conséquent et on constate d'ailleurs que
le gouvernement français prévoit une
croissance américaine de 1,4 pour cent
pour 2013 et 2,6 pour cent pour 2014 et
que ses prévisions sont plus prudentes
que les le scénario central qui a été
publié par la fed le le 18 septembre
dernier puisque la fête se montre dans
son scénario central plus optimiste que
le scénario retenu par le gouvernement
on peut penser compte tenu de tout cela
que la demande intérieure peut soutenir
la croissance en 2014 que l'inflation
pourrait se redresser graduellement mais
tout en restant modérées mais que malgré
ses fondamentaux qui s'améliore sur le
plan de la situation américaine
bon nous attirons l'attention sur le
fait que les risques qui entourent les
perspectives de croissance américaine ne
doivent pas non plus être sous-estimée
il ya la question monétaire dont vous
avez parlé alors peut-être que la
nomination qui devrait intervenir
aujourd'hui peut permettre d'avoir une
appréciation optimiste par rapport à la
politique monétaire qui sera conduite
par
la fed mais bon on sait que ces
choses-là sont fines entre sur la
détermination du bon moment pour
resserrer la politique monétaire est pas
une tâche facile une sortie trop rapide
pourrait être néfaste à la reprise
bon je pense que meilleur la nouvelle
autorité de en est conscient elle a fait
quelques déclarations en ce sens
en revanche attendre trop longtemps peut
aussi avoir des risques et favorisé des
prises de risque justement excessive sur
les marchés financiers comme il s'en est
produit
il y a encore peu de temps
et puis il y as je dirais les
incertitudes qui entourent la politique
budgétaire n'avions pas obligatoirement
séisme
au moment où nous avons formulé notre
avis mais on voit bien dans quelle
situation aujourd'hui des états unis
sont il ya des échéances
bon le plus plu l'accord qui doit être
trouvée au niveau du kong américain
tarde plus il peut y avoir des
conséquences bien évidemment sur la
croissance américaine et donc avec des
répercussions possibles sur la
croissance mondiale et au niveau de la
croissance européenne
il y avait une dernière question sur les
hypothèses de croissance tendancielle
des dépenses publiques alors là aussi le
haut conseil ne produit pas ses propres
prévisions
nous ne sommes pas du tout armé pour
pour le faire ses propres prévisions
macro économique et de finances
publiques ce n'est pas sa mission est en
tout cas ce n'est pas le texte que vous
avez voté
bon donc il ne nous est pas ne sommes
pas l'idée c'est un bon et nous n'avons
pas les moyens de concurrencer l'insee
pour faire des nos propres prévisions
macro économique et donc nous n'avons
pas capacités nous mêmes à faire nos
propres prévisions et le haut conseil
n'a pas été amenés non plus à retenir
des hypothèses de croissance
tendancielle des dépenses nous sommes là
nous pour apprécier la cohérence des
prévisions le caractère crédible au nom
des hypothèses macroéconomiques la
robustesse de ses prévisions et la
cohérence de ses prévisions par rapport
à tout un ensemble et notamment par
rapport à la loi de programmation nous
cesser c'est notre mission nous n'avons
pas capacité à examiner les écarts avec
je dirais d'autres textes votre
programmation la loi organique est très
claire ce qui vous amène bien évidemment
à porter l'appréciation que nous portons
sur le décalage alors sur les hypothèses
d'élasticité je pourrais y revenir si
vous le souhaitez pour manifestement
pour 2013 on voit bien qu'il ya eu un
écart bon l'élasticité
finale n'a pas été celle prévue bon et
avec un décalage relativement important
puisqu'il est de l'ordre de 0,5 point
pour 2014 si elle investit cité qui est
prévu entre 0 9 et 1 point proche du
pib' là aussi on considère que que que
cette hypothèse peut être optimiste à
partir du moment où elle peut
sous-estimer les effets négatifs de la
mauvaise conjoncture de 2013 on voit
bien qu'on a un petit problème
d'ailleurs au niveau de l'estimation
d'aider des recettes
recettes fiscales bon donc il y à il y a
un lien par rapport aux hypothèses
d'élasticité et on considère qu'il peut
y avoir un risque quand 2014
l'élasticité soit encore inférieur au
pic tel fils peut-être réalisé sur sur
l'année alors après il y à là la
question du président alors il le sait
je pense qu'il doit s'attendre à ma
réponse qui ne m'appartient pas de
commenter une déclaration d'un membre du
gouvernement
ça n'est pas dans ma qualité je ne
souhaite pas mais levé au dessus de ma
de ma condition
le mans c'est rien mais en tout cas
m'appartient pas de commenter est ce qu
a dit le haut conseil relève du constat
et et d'ailleurs nous faisons d'autant
plus facilement ce constat l'aurions
fait mais que le gouvernement lui-même
fait état de ce décalage par rapport à
la loi de programmation donc ne pouvons
pas dire autre chose que ce que nous
disons sur un décalage entre ce qui peut
se produire en 2014 sur le déficit
structurel et sur l'effort structurel à
conduire ensuite sur les années
suivantes que ce que nous nous disons
parce que c'est là aussi la référence
c'est la loi de programmation bien
évidemment nous ajoutons la précaution
sauf si la vague programmation venait à
changer mais nous appartient pas là
aussi de suggérer ou de proposer une
modification dans votre programmation ça
appartient bien évidemment aux pouvoirs
politiques nous nous apprécions une
situation par rapport à un texte donne
est bon s'il est actualisée bien
évidemment nous devons nous en ce qui
nous concerne à ce moment là en tenir
compte
ce que je constate c'est que déjà le
rapport économique et financier avance
un certain nombre d'éléments
complémentaires par rapport aux éléments
qui nous est qu'ils nous ont été
apportées par ce que il prévoit que fin
il confirme d'ailleurs que la france ne
remet pas en cause l'objectif
d'équilibré structurel de nos comptes en
mais avec la marge de souplesse ou
d'erreurs que reconnaît elle-même
l'europe à savoir 0,25 point et dans le
rapport économique et financier
ses + 0 qui est prévu comme la loi de
programmation le prévoit mais c'est zéro
virgule
2 et d'où un effort structurel qui n'est
pas aussi important que celui que nous
avions identifiés par référence à la loi
de programmation mais qui reste plus
important bien évidemment que celui
prévu dans la loi de programmation elle
même donc ça veut dire qu'en 2015 et
2016 en tout état de cause il faut faire
un effort structurel plus important que
celui prévu par l'actuelle loi de
programmation
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général ceux de madame des
sénateurs les réponses que je pouvais
apporter aux questions que vous avez
commencé à me poser
eh bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
président que nous aider ainsi à
ausculter la bouteille que l'on voit
tantôt à moitié vide en toi moitié plein
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition de
didier migaud le premier président de la
cour des comptes et président du haut
conseil des finances publiques devant la
commission des finances du sénat tout de
suite vous retrouvez delphine girard
pour 24 heures c'est là